[Music]
we're here post Bachelorette finale
Rachel and Brian are now together and
they are about to head into that world
one that you'd know so well and have
experienced what would you tell them
about how to adjust to life post show
well I don't know if we did it right or
wrong I feel strange telling people how
to do it but I think obviously you don't
get engaged to someone unless you love
them and care about them I would say
continue to put that first put your
relationship first be my number one
piece of advice it was such a big thing
on rachel season to the proposal yeah
I'm gonna thinking maybe there shouldn't
be a proposal at the end maybe you
should just be like you find a
relationship and then it wouldn't be
this added pressure but I don't know
that she would ever do that I don't know
yeah whatever feels right honestly and
sometimes something might feel right at
that moment and then later on it might
not feel right and that's that's life
like you don't know it's hard to
determine what tomorrow looks like let
alone a year from now or two years so I
would say go with your heart or follow
your heart do what feels right
[Music]